so i guess switching gears did you guys
hear about this like deep fake story
that happens
i think today or yesterday so yesterday
for us but it would be like three weeks
for the audience yeah three weeks three
weeks for the audience
facts may come out i mean yeah i have
not like with deep fake becoming like
such a
big thought like a bigger thing now so i
i
can't we're gonna go back to this like i
can't remember every detail of the story
but i think the main gist of it was
there was his mom and she had a daughter
who was on the cheerleading squad i
didn't get marlene to check the story
while talking about it yeah just google
deep fake news that'll be like a top
story
so i believe there was mom who had a
daughter who was on the cheerleading
squad
um and there were other girls on that
cheerleading squad
and for some reason she wanted the
she wanted to kick these other girls off
of the squad
right so what she did is she made some
deep fakes
for like of the other girls like smoking
yeah like smoking drinking
doing doing like bad illegal activities
or whatever right and i think
threatening them with it right like i
can't remember if she threatened them or
she sent them straight to the sure how
she did it but i think they they saw it
and the reason why it got even found out
was because they took it to the police
yeah a few of them went to the police
yeah and how she got found out was she
used the fake number
she used like this internet service that
gave them gave her a fake number
but that didn't hide her ip address and
that's the only reason she found out
this episode is sponsored by
you know i don't think she would have
got caught if she was sponsored by
i don't think our sponsor would be very
happy now that's why we're not going to
mention
any names yeah but i mean i i saw it and
i'm just like well i can't believe they
actually took
this long something like this to happen
you know the most unbelievable part of
the story is
there's a mum out there that's tech
savvy enough because my mother that's
what i thought
might you i don't even think my mom
knows what a [ __ ] deep fake is let
alone how to she doesn't even know how
to search for files on windows
i'm actually impressed her mom knew how
to make a difference because i'm
impressed
i'm impressed that mom knew how to do a
deep fake but i'm even more like
because okay um i'm not sure if any of
this is confirmed
so i'm gonna put out a disclaimer that
we could be totally wrong this could be
please check this out by the time this
comes out
all right all right i'll cut the story
awhile by the time this come out comes
out everything might be confirmed this
might all
have been like false information or it
would it might have just been like
claims but at the time of recording we
don't know if it's real or not
but these are what the allegations are
and the allegation was that she did this
because
the daughters on the cheerleading squad
she stopped hanging out with her
daughter
and so she she wanted to get them kicked
off because of that and i'm just
thinking
if someone's this petty to be this crazy
how dare you are not how does she manage
to figure out how to do deep fakes they
all she also
sent them anonymous messages telling
them to that they should you know end
their own lives as well to the these
kids
the mom did that the mom did that what
the [ __ ] this [ __ ]
how this is something some people are
not supposed to be parents this is so
like cartoon villain like it's so absurd
that someone could be this
[ __ ] oh my god yeah but
i mean i saw that and i'm just thinking
my first thought was i'm
one i'm surprised that it took this long
for something like this to happen right
this mug shot looks like she's tore
someone's face off
oh my god no she looks like a disney
villain doesn't it yeah
maleficent just ripped someone's face
off and stitched that's like
that it's pretty too going too far isn't
it that's like that's like i should [ __ ]
you
there's more concerning about that that
was someone's parent yeah holy
[ __ ] imagine being raised by someone
like that
holy [ __ ] that kid's going to be [ __ ]
up
but apparently the kid knew nothing like
the mom did this without telling the kid
she did this by herself so
how do you even tell the kid like the
kid's like are you cool with this kid
no i'm not mum what's wrong with you
there's replying back to a nasty tweet
and then there's creating deep faith
please please don't tell my schoolmates
to go kill themselves and make sense
when i would tell my mom that i was
being bullied she wasn't thrilled about
it yeah but
she was like you know i'm not happy
about this i'm putting a word to the
teacher but you're on your own
yeah yeah this is your problem exactly
like i can't deal with this [ __ ]
i don't even know what's going on
they're like i mean [ __ ] hell that's
scary i mean it's just so many these the
the parts of this story is
actually insane yeah that this could
happen it is literally like a horror
movie plot
what this is this is kind of like it's
just it's almost too cartoony to be a
black mirror episode
that's what that's what it is it is it's
so like if this was a blackberry episode
you'd be like yeah twist's really
predictable like really
really over the top yeah i mean like
it's like a b-grade horror film right
like the mom's kind of an unbelievable
villain here
she could have used more character
development more motivation no this is
reality
but what scares me is that like
what what does this mean for the future
of deep fakes now because like
uh this week especially this new app's
come up where
it's gotten really easy to deflate yeah
you know deep flake you know
use use it for memes use it for harmless
memes to make people sing
[ __ ] buckami thai i mean you know
we're used to
you know people doing [ __ ] terrible
photoshops or doing stuff yeah so if
someone sent me a video of me doing
something i clearly didn't do or never
ever did i'd be like
i don't really give a [ __ ] it's fake
right and i'll say it's fake and yeah
that'll probably be the end of it
but to someone who's never really had
anything online or any kind of like
you know posted anything about
themselves inside of their personal
facebook i can see why receiving
a video that looks like you doing
something that you didn't do could be
[ __ ] terrible yeah
right absolutely you would think that
wow people are really gonna believe this
even though you know realistically
they're probably not going to he
explained that it's fake
right yeah i mean it's gotten to a point
where like for people like us especially
where we show our faces
on camera pretty often it wouldn't be
hard to make a convincing deep fake with
you know us coming on camera literally
every week i think we all uh we all
agree on this that you do not have
permission to make any deep fakes of us
and we don't condone any of them by the
way just saying that
you're legally not allowed to do that
yeah i mean is there anything legal
that's
you know that yeah you can't you're not
like i think legally speaking you can't
like
just do that um depending on what
jurisdiction you're in
yeah tom scott did a video about it
right um i think i think the laws around
it but iffy and obviously
stuff like this always takes because
it's such a new thing yeah yeah exactly
it's a really new thing because like you
know i've seen like the buckingham thai
deep fake someone just like you know
this is
funny meme whatever but then i don't
know how it i would feel if i saw the
uh you know the ksi ainslie harriet deep
fake because that's that's
so good that's so good it's funny as
[ __ ] but then
also something at the back of my mind
which makes me
like that's [ __ ] worrying that's how
good like how good it is and
i'm glad it's been used as a funny meme
but my god if if i saw if i saw my face
on somebody else like that
i would just think damn i'm glad this is
being used
for a funny meme but this could be used
for something that's really luckily
right now
as many deep fake things are being made
there's just as many things that are
detecting if deep fakes have been made
like programs that are being written to
detect them
and so right now it's like it's a lot of
software's will detect when the when
it's a deep fake
yeah but whether it'll get to the point
in future
that it is do you think like it's only a
matter of time before we get our first
deep fake cancellation
no i think we're quite far away from
that right i think i think they're still
too rough and the technology isn't there
yet but i think it's possible within
like
i've seen some defects that are really
[ __ ] convincing though
but like the the videos are like always
in like 480p
max right like and well that's like kind
of the video you'd expect for i don't
know like the
kind of phone quality exposed videos
they're never like 720p
4k it's always like [ __ ] playstation
eye camera but i think the
the more the easier it gets to cancel
someone from a deep fake the less
cancelling will happen because everyone
will be like it's a deep fake
is it a deep fake or everyone's going to
defense is going to be it's a deep fake
yeah all right but like how did that
video of me punching a baby
that's the thing how long until the deep
fake argument is going to be legitimate
right
yeah yeah well i mean the moment that
you can counter someone for a deep fake
is when that argument will become valid
right because they'll be like oh i mean
are you sure you saw that do you think
it was yeah
that's a really good defense looks so
real
oh my god i can't believe it myself our
world's going to become a lot more messy
when he gets there unfortunately
but you know it's uh yeah i mean there's
nothing what's scary is that there's
nothing to stop the technology being out
there but i mean i
guess you can argue this for a lot of
things because i remember when you know
3d printers became a thing and then
like well you can still 3d print guns
yeah exactly
you can still 3d print guns you
shouldn't but i mean you shouldn't and i
believe it's illegal
right uh well it's it's most around it
real
weird i think i think i think what it is
is that there's most uh
3d printing machines can detect if it's
like the blueprint of a gun or firearm
or something and just
not well it's like a photoshop if you
put a picture of the the dollar bill in
uh they won't let you do anything to it
yeah it'll like stop you oh really
yeah i had no idea because yeah it's so
they don't want to photoshop it to like
try and like you know
because the software is so powerful
photoshop print out free money yeah
photoshop is
really powerful tool yeah and the stuff
that they're constantly adding to it is
just
you know adding to the repertoire of how
strong it is and it's like very
concerning
but then again you know it's like when
photoshop first started as well like we
were all like oh my god
people are going to be like it's it's
crazy you know like
everyone's going to start getting
canceled they're going to be people
going to put nicholas cage in orgies
although that's really i mean that's
not my realist bad example
we've